[Music]
was killed on December 15 near the
airport in the city of ayakulture in the
Andes his family says they have no doubt
he'd been gunned down by the Army who'd
opened fire on protesters that afternoon
Leonardo was among 10 people killed the
question for his wife Ruth is who was in
command
who gave the order to kill and repress a
peaceful March
Amnesty International says most of the
victims in more than two months of
turmoil were killed by Security Forces
who unlawfully fired lethal weapons and
used other less lethal ones
indiscriminately in their Crackdown on
protesters we are not only facing
serious human rights violations but
crimes under international law there's
been widespread attacks against
civilians which implies individualized
criminal responsibility including those
at the highest level who have allowed
violations to continue
a preliminary report says at least 48
people died by state repression and 80
percent were killed in indigenous
populated areas a show of contempt
against indigenous peruvians it says our
rights have been violated because we are
peasants Dina bolawate has said we are
terrorists vandals human rights lawyers
representing victims say in addition
there's a pattern in the killings in
different regions
it could be that these are not
individual cases but political decisions
turned into orders to the armed forces
and police and for that reason we can
see an escalation in their actions and a
denial of responsibility
president
amnesty Representatives on Wednesday she
says the Judiciary is investigating the
cases and they're waiting for its
findings but amnesty says they're
worried because authorities have not
guaranteed they will refrain from
quelling future protests with excessive
use of force Mariana Sanchez